here with more trump attorney who was
blocked from viewing the search at
mar-a-lago lindsey halligan is with us
lindsay thank you for being with us
let's talk about that day let's talk
about the fbi arriving what happened
hi mr hannity uh so i arrived around 11
a.m
and there were about 30 to 40 fbi agents
that i saw
five of which were wearing suits the
rest were in
cargo pants masks and gloves
and they basically had unfettered access
to the property they refused to talk to
me refused to let me in all i knew is
that they were
searching
areas one two and three which i
understood to be
the former president's bedroom
his office and a storage room
and other than that we were not allowed
to talk to them or go inside at all
did you ever get a chance to read the
warrant did you ever get a copy of it
did you ever get any other information
do you know are you aware what they took
out of mar-a-lago
that's the thing
they had unfettered access to the
property they looked at god knows what
in there and did god knows what in there
we have no idea
what the fbi did was an appalling
display of abuse of power all documents
requested were previously handed over
president trump and his team
painstakingly reviewed every single
document at mar-a-lago and gave the
government what they requested
if they needed any other documents they
could have just asked
and the warrant was
secured under seal so they tried to get
away with concealing this overreach by
obtaining a warrant
under seal nobody knew about it they
knew that president trump was in
bedminster and hasn't been at mar-a-lago
for some time they thought they could
sneak in snoop around without attorneys
present
in case they walked out with nothing so
nobody would know that they overreached
to this degree and it's unprecedented in
united states history
the government seems to be out of
control it's plagued with manipulation
corruption greed deceit and fraud
and yet the national archives praised
the
the the working relationship that you
had back in february and my
understanding is they were there as
recently as june and they were the ones
that requested
the padlock on on one particular door
where there was some documents that they
could have taken with them that day
correct yes
that was when they came to the property
and
they went through documents to my
understanding they requested that a
padlock be put on the door and then they
broke through that padlock
just the other day you know we have a
sitting u.s president whose son has
committed a myriad of felonies a speaker
of the house whose husband drove a car
under the influence of alcohol drugs
with a concealed undisclosed passenger
in the car
a secret list of undisclosed powerful
people that visited epstein's island and
did god knows what to underage women
and none of whose liberties have been
infringed upon like president trump's
and his families simply put it seems
that under the biden administration the
government conceals what it wants to the
government does what it wants to an
american citizens need to protect
their country from its government
lindsay anything else you'd want the
american people to know you were there
that day what should they know anything
else
well if we're thinking about the future
i'd like to just say that the biden
administration has united americans
against its administration and it has
this this incident has ironically
created bipartisan bipartisanship on
this issue
because no american whether democrat or
republican wants an overreaching
department of justice we even see andrew
cuomo and andrew yang speaking out about
this
the silence of the biden administration
and the fbi is deafening americans are
listening and watching
all right we really appreciate your time
lindsay halligan thank you thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else